hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the super spoopy game of
devilry where you play as a father
trying to protect your family from the
ghosty goos in the darkness that's lit
what is whoa what the hell can't send
okay oh so there's different types of
games I'm not gonna go on the normal
defeat the ghost all I got to do cuz I
don't even think I'm gonna be able to do
that correctly so basically your whole
family is ain't haunted by ghosts you
have to kill the ghost somehow and you
have to go through your house and you
have to pick up stuff and you have to be
able to try to kill this ghost Clara hey
Damien it's getting a little late I'm
just putting the kids to bed and calling
it a night
no problem I'll be home in half an hour
apparently I'm texting on a big heads-up
display on my face oh okay check coming
why am I just standing in the middle of
night did I Drive up did I walk up kind
of Haunted Mansion do we Lukey
nevermind I'm gonna take this a bit more
seriously now hello baby you don't look
so good why is why is my why why is it
getting darker and lighter oh is that
because the clouds of the Moon no it's
not because of the clouds that'd be
ridiculous
hello how do I go use door thank you for
telling me I usually expect these games
not to tell me what to do so it's good
that it news what I'm supposed to do
hello is anybody here okay so I got the
kitchen over y'all I need to go find my
family
loo oh I got way too many that looked a
little weird
Liz's
wait whoa who put this candle here who
did all this why is this house set up to
be specifically huh
why is there a side door oh I thought I
saw something in the distance
okay want to close that because that's
unnecessary and evil I don't like any of
this Oh
history a man so estate 1826 tragic
story commences when the only child of
the families lost to weather and illness
stricken with grief the mother and
father cope poorly with the loss okay
cool am I about to do the same because
of all this is haunted great
oh another door out what is this who
keeps leaving thank you very much oh I
need to check up on my family I didn't
do that yes I think okay just gonna turn
that off now okay ooh this house is not
fun where's my flashlight I don't have a
flashlight
no Facebook message get out of here oh
that's no good
all right then I forgot I left that what
is that what is that yeah what is that
then Oh
huh maybe I should stop being creeper in
my own house and just check out my damn
family hello this is weird it's a good
idea to frequently check out mama
where's my family is that my family
oh you're snoring
I shouldn't yell at you good night Ellen
my wife I'm guessing whoa what is that
oh oh no no this is God that's got to be
a kid with the stars on the door I can't
see anything I can't okay sorry
am i waking you up dear wife okay good
good well thank you I don't like any of
this I like exactly none of this isn't
someone snoring why do I need to this
doesn't make any sense
number one to nine years what oh oh oh
ow
oh no oh this is so weird oh no oh that
teddy bear at the corner so creepy
oh this is creepy where's Aiden where
the heck is Aiden oh this is bad
Jesus don't do that to me none of that
know that I wish I had a flashlight
where's Aiden is that oh god I can't see
a thing okay so there was a door there
oh I can't see a thing
where am I with seriously where the hell
am I
Wow I can oh oh okay oh good
I have full health why would a tap be
able to fix that
yeah goddamn is dark in here
I cannot see a damn thing is that stairs
up do I have oh yeah I'm not going up
there I don't have a friggin flashlight
where's the goddamn flashlight I need a
goddamn flashlight I can't see well
maybe I should close the front door okay
your flashlight Oh fear sweeps the
villages a local child goes missing fear
to me okay okay cool
free to be kidnapped parents outside
they stay at the time notice the gone
female intruder in the night okay uh why
does it do that
why does it do that where does it do
that is why do we have two fridges was
some kind of rich family here I can't
see anything
that goes into the basement me no likey
oh god damn it
okay I have this now is the baby in the
basement did somebody put baby in the
corner of the basement why is it baby so
big no no no no no what does that cost
trash bag okay I shouldn't be down here
I should go upstairs I should find my
baby I needed to check on Adrian for a
long time good let's just go let's go
let's go
okay now that I can actually see where
I'm going I should be able to find the
baby Eden are you in here
Oh lovely wife you bothered I'm filled
with father oh that's comforting okay
I've got to find this baby baby baby
baby baby
where's goddamn baby baby that's weird
baby oh here go
different objects are now scattered
around the house search them out why why
do I do that why are you so creepy why a
lot of things huh should I go outside
why don't I just go to bed
seriously why don't start I'm going back
inside thank you yeah why don't I just
go to bed
seriously why don't I just go to sleep
what's wrong with me how do I know
there's ghosts why is there so much
ruined Eligius memorabilia on the walls
okay what does that what's with that
okay lovely wife I thought I saw that
open lovely wife how are you doing buddy
sleepy Oh what is this
woo this looks fancy why do I need this
whoa okay Oh like this huh oh I forgot
about them oh I forgot about the Attic
daughter how are you doing how you doing
in here
sorry any reason for this I've given the
most paranoid delusional dad ever whoa
Emily completely distraught experienced
a physical and mental breakdown in her
madness she killed her husband and
herself oh good I got a toy cube for
some reason okay I'll go upstairs fine
bring it on douche canoe what are you
gonna do about me you want to bring it
on oh okay I got an axe why okay I'm
sure I'm racking up a lot of points no
no oh god why did I do that
oh I'm such a delusional parent I'm
burning my entire house down why where'd
my oh where my candle go ow owie ow ow
where my candle go damn but where my
candle go Oh ma'am I can't go I gotta
get a candle I gotta get out of here I
gotta get out of here no I got an axe I
will murder you I'm no okay okay okay
okay
can I have this oh god I lost my candle
oh no no you
okay I got it back hidden so far north
the de villain of Keppel experiences
cold rain an almost permanent nighttime
last comforting what is that
who's that who's that who's that poser
poser all right what is I what is I
what are you yeah I haven't actually
seen anything yet well I don't like this
I'm gonna check out my family I guess
mmm-hmm hello he's still alive good good
oh okay what's how are you
you okay you okay okay good god don't
mind you're extremely crazy father oh hi
baby
goddamn you're so creepy why why why in
a baby's room why in a baby's room I
can't see anything
leapin sadly okay wife are you doing
that bear why why why why why why why
what do they do
I got points up for some reason why why
oh I'm getting something I'm picking up
some oh I'm getting points
I might skin points for class in the
camera probably I am just some paranoid
delusional dad who has no reason to be
doing this to be up this late at night
no reason to be paranoid
they've see I've seen nothing out of the
ordinary and frankly I'm just disturbing
my entire family or all the paintings
changing to fat also that's still weird
I'm gonna go outside okay
why I'm doing this hello-o floodlight
okay
motion sensor okay huh I am just the
weirdest dad in the world stomping
around my yard
I need to take pictures it's a UV camera
are you still sleeping family this is
beautiful is it a ghost
probably I'm not crazy are you crazy I'm
done any type of crazy y'all crazy for
taking y'all crazy
oh do you guys hear music I'm listening
to the radio and hearing beeps and
Boop's really exciting what's that No
what is that oh I see something Oh Oh
God get away
okay okay vows normal doing what are you
doing in there
what do I do with you take some of that
how about a toy cube wanna Kubb you want
a cuvette no no no no yeah that's right
no you can't go past that door huh oh
you're gone oh you're not there anymore
I see okay hello are you knocking over
my [ __ ] what does that sound you down
there down there down here what's that
spotlight oh oh okay
what the hell what is this why why does
that exist sorry I'm losing my voice why
does that exist
Oh someone's very unhappy what the hell
okay oh okay oh oh oh no okay huh oh no
what why-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y aah - wake
up
I guess honey the bit of a problem yet
Oh mind me wife I was just vomiting
because I'm apparently a giant drunk up
here vomiting everywhere oh okay Oh Oh
my voice can't take that okay oh man I
need to stop I need to stop I need to
stop oh [ __ ]
all I need to stop okay
whoo hello you're open all right then I
think I need to get this spotlight again
and I need to set it up where I know
she's gonna be in the blaster that's
what I need to do this door classic did
I get her did I get did I do it no she
wasn't in there damn it
okay okay okay what what the hell
happened oh my god I have no idea okay
so I have no idea what I was supposed to
do I think I had an idea and if I would
caught her with spotlight I might have
been able to kill her but I honestly
have no idea and I like I screamed my
voice out which is not a good thing so I
gotta stop here thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think of this game in the comments down
below I was just paranoid I was so
paranoid the whole time I had no idea
what to expect it's not a bad game it's
actually pretty good but there's just so
much confusion that I had no idea what
it wanted for me so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you think of this game in the comments
down below and you can play for yourself
and link in the description check out
the other scare games that I've done in
the playlist below and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
made it a little bit what what is having
wife and why is Jeff